Should anyone here know of any
reason that this couple should
not be joined in
holy matrimony, speak now
or forever hold
your peace.
Really? Nobody's gonna object?
We're all just gonna
let this happen?
What is the objection?
I didn't want to be a hero,
but, you know what?
My ankle tattoo
says "Carpe Diem."
Seize the carp.
So, fine.
Stop the wedding.
Amy, what
the (bleep)?
What the (bleep)
you, Sasha.
I'm gonna say it.
What are you talking about?
I was outside, bumming
a smoke yesterday,
after the free
rehearsal dinner.
Thank you guys so
much for that.
And I'm outside
and I remember
that I overheard something
interesting that one of
your bridesmaids told me.
Who?
Which bridesmaid?
Okay, which one did I talk
to yesterday?
Okay.
You asked me to help
you find your car.
I said you shouldn't be driving
because you seemed drunk.
No. Before that.
Before that,
wiseass.
What-- No, what did you say?
You told me something really
revealing about Chris.
Right?
What's your name?
Pam.
That's not it.
No. Sit down.
Right down.
Do not sit down.
(Amy)
Sit down, Pam.
There's an elephant in the
room, y'all, and it stanks!
Everybody wants
you to stop.
You do, Chris.
But this side of
the room has my back
and so do other people.
I'm looking at you,
Janine.
She told me also.
What are you
talking about?
Grow up!
Janine gave me a piece
of gum earlier.
She also dished
some dirt too.
Are you done?
Are you done lying,
Chris?
Don't forget, you hooked
up with me in college.
That was me.
You're also a
piece of (bleep).
No, I'm not.
Fair enough.
Only time will tell.
But for now,
cat's out of the bag.
(meows)
Wake up.
Wake up,
San Francisco.
I don't know.
I believe the answer to all
your questions is right here.
I think I had written something
down earlier about this.
Oh, I have gum.
Do you want this?
You don't care.
Is there something
you need to tell me?
Of course not,
babe.
Okay.
Are you sure?
Okay, fine.
I'm gay,
I (bleep) dudes.